really fast I want to tell you about our
sponsor bespoke post the subscription
club for men every month you get a
brand-new box filled with high quality
products to spice up your everyday life
in my box I got a set of really high
quality beer glasses from Germany as
well as a beer growler made of amber
glass designed to prevent sunlight from
spoiling your beer in another box I got
these really great handmade sunglasses
that I'm wearing every month you get
totally new unique gear worth more than
what you're paying no commitments
customized your box every month send
stuff back if you don't like it click
the link right under this video to take
their quiz and get suggestions about
which bespoke post boxes might be best
for you ok I seriously hate that I have
to do this story today but I have
information about what is happening on
YouTube which is an extraordinarily
important agenda-setting platform at
this point in the world of news and
politics
it just is whether we want it to be or
not it is and what I have to tell you
today is terrible and if I didn't tell
you I wouldn't be doing my job I'm
actually worried that I'm going to get
and what we might call trouble in some
way for me even doing this story today
but what is taking place has to be made
as widely known as possible so that we
can at least try to take control back of
what's going on what is taking place is
that Google has unofficially but sort of
officially made YouTube corporate media
at this point in time when it comes to
news in politics ok YouTube used to be
about independent content of all kinds
alternatives to corporate media that
applied a lot to news in politics but
now as I have been suspecting for months
and have been telling you for weeks
they have rewired their algorithm and
are almost completely stopping
recommendations of independent news and
politics channels like this one like sam
cedars majority report kyle kolinsky
secular talk and are instead
recommending people watch instead CNN's
YouTube channel Fox News's YouTube
channel MSNBC's and other legacy
corporate media channels now I don't
want to redo the whole story because
there's so much new data that I have for
today and again I could get destroyed by
YouTube for doing this but I'm I have to
tell you because what's going on and
what we've uncovered is is absolutely
stunning just to refresh a little bit
our channel has been getting fewer and
fewer views from YouTube's recommended
video algorithm when you watch videos on
YouTube YouTube suggests other things to
watch alongside or below the video the
idea is to keep you watching as long as
possible
okay we used to get a lot of recommended
video views from YouTube's algorithm I
told you previously I estimated that we
had lost about two million views per
month from this algorithm recommending
our videos more and more infrequently
that was a massive underestimate there's
a disturbing new metric I looked at on
YouTube some of the people watching our
videos like anybody else's some of the
people are subscribers and some aren't
okay of course you don't have to be a
subscriber to a YouTube channel to watch
the videos on that channel we have lost
millions of non subscriber views per
month over the last several months and
non-subscriber views are determined by
YouTube's algorithm ok this graphic
we're putting up on the screen is
disgusting the numbers of views from
subscribers has slowly trickled up which
makes sense as we gain subscribers over
time we get a few more views from
subscribers over time that's the blue
line on the bottom it's a slow uptick
the red line is non subscriber views
this is determined wholly totally by the
YouTube algorithm eight million
non-subscriber views in December just a
straight line decline down to under five
million in June a short fall not of two
million views a month as I thought but
of three million views per month most
channels don't even get three million
views ever even most active YouTube
channels don't get three million views
per year nevermind per month and our
shortfall from the decline of only non
subscriber views is more than three
million views per month it's a lot of
money for us
not gonna lie now lots of people wrote
in and said David okay you're losing
views from the algorithm but
who is gaining them if you really are
right about this if the YouTube audience
continues to grow if you are losing
views from the recommended video
algorithm someone must be gaining those
views and that is exactly right and I
spent the weekend researching this and I
am now ready to tell you exactly who is
gaining and it's all corporate channels
you are likely going to be disgusted by
this but maybe not surprised a guy named
mark LED which put together a tool from
publicly available recommendation data
where you can look at the percentages of
recommendations within news and politics
to different channels let's put this
first image up on the screen what you
will notice and I'll describe it to
people who aren't watching is that on
May 1st something very specific happened
the david pakman show kyle kolinsky sam
cedar now i'm even including steven
crowder here because i want to show you
that this does not appear to be
politically biased all of the
recommended views as a percentage of
those days news and politics
recommendations dropped off a cliff
while at the exact same time the
recommended views for CNN's YouTube
channel and MSNBC's and Fox News's
increased if you look before May first
channels like mine and others we're
getting somewhere in the range of 1 to 3
percent of the recommended views in news
and politics from this broader list of
some of the largest news and politics
channels on May 1st those numbers
crashed and they went from between 1 and
3 percent to between 0.03 percent and
half a percent now you might think well
those are all small numbers 1 to 3
percent down to 0.03 to 0.5% that's not
a big difference understand that this is
a pool of it's either hundreds of
millions or billions of total views if I
am getting 0.1% of the recommendations
and before I was getting 1.5 percent
that is a decline of greater than 90
percent okay on the same day early May
of this year CNN MSNBC and Fox went from
getting in the case of Fox News's
YouTube channel 5 to 8 percent of the
recommended views all the way to 12 to
18 percent
that's a 50% increase of recommended
views for Fox's YouTube channel CNN
MSNBC same thing now they may come after
me for going public with this and if
that happens I'm going to let you know
but this is serious because it could
literally decimate channels like mine
and others that you might like
whether you like channels on the left or
right I don't care it doesn't matter
this appears to be affecting channels of
all political persuasions let me show
you another image just comparing the
David Pakman show and CNN so it's easier
to read the data it's not as scrunched
as you can see the same day may 1:29
teen and it remains the case since then
CNN spikes and we drop let's look at
another example compare the david pakman
show YouTube channel to MSNBC again this
is not left/right maybe some of that
exists but this is pro corporate and
anti independent okay so I hope it's
clear now the direction this is going I
had many phone calls over the weekend
with all sorts of hosts but we don't
think we can do a damn thing about this
as far as YouTube's algorithm we're all
exploring options we're all worried but
ultimately if YouTube is going to do
this I don't know what we can do that's
completely within their right to do this
I just think it is a perversion of their
original sort of existence which was
independent content now just the same
old legacy corporate content that people
get through cable subscriptions this is
a decision that is anti independent pro
corporate views go from independent
channels to Fox News which is right-wing
editorially they go from independent
channels to MSNBC which is center-left
editorially but they're both huge
corporate news that is the point now in
the meantime there's a ton of crazy
stuff on YouTube that's going totally
unplanned it's stunning example there
are YouTube ads running for video games
which clearly violate the copyright of
for example Nintendo take a look at this
this is an ad for a game called Super
Mario maker - this is clearly not a
Nintendo game this is clearly a total
violation of Nintendo's copyright on
Mario and yet it's on YouTube making
money and paying for ads another example
last week I told you that Gavin McInnes
the right-wing proud boys founder his
content was briefly ban
from YouTube then allowed back on the
vast majority of the content is not what
would be called brand safe
he is advertising on YouTube even though
the content itself is not considered
brand safe what is happening here so
this is very quickly employed imploding
weekly this is getting worse so the only
solution is to separate revenue from
advertising okay if we separate the
revenue that shows like hours get from
the whims of YouTube's algorithmic
decisions we make ourselves immune to
this toxic and disgusting failed system
that has been identified as toxic and
failing for a very long time and it sort
of comes and goes in waves and what I'm
talking about is you just got to support
the shows you like directly we make it
really easy okay if you go to join
pakman.com you can sign up in under a
minute it's not a lot of money if you
buy one of those lattes a month and I
hate these latte comparisons but they
are sometimes illuminating if you buy
one latte per month you can give us 3 or
4 bucks a month and it'll actually make
a really big difference we estimate only
1% of our entire audience supports us
financially if we can get it to 2% or 3%
or imagine we can get it to 5% the
YouTube issue is no longer a problem we
just focus on doing stories that we want
to do that are the valuable stories that
the audience wants us to do ok so we can
take ownership of what's going on we
can't control YouTube's algorithm but if
we understand membership culture if we
say let's just support the programs we
like we might spend a hundred bucks a
month on a cable subscription mostly for
channels we don't even actually watch or
want to support I'll send David Pakman
six bucks or I'll go on patreon and send
them a dollar a month we do have a
coupon code on our website it's this is
2020 it will give you a 40% discount
I want you involved at any level because
even a dollar a month is really valuable
when you have 700,000 subscribers on
YouTube and several hundred thousand
podcast listeners etc etc even just
people throwing in a dollar or two a
month makes a big difference June was
our second best month ever for new
members I would like to make July the
best ever and if we do that I will tell
you that that's something that we've
done I seriously hate that this is
happening I want to be talking to other
hosts not about are we gonna lose 90% or
80% of our YouTube revenue I want to be
talking to them about what's the best
content we can make how are you covering
the upcoming election are we going to
the conventions are we doing live
broadcast of debates I hate that this
has become the topic and if they come
after me for talking publicly about it
and sharing this data with you I'm going
to let you know believe me but in the
immediate whether it's this show or
other shows if you have a few extra
bucks a month this is a really good time
to say I am NOT going to allow this to
destroy programs I find valuable join
pakman.com get a membership and i'll
update you later this week as to what's
going on and how things are going really
really sad state of affairs